go ahead and perfect so yeah let's go ahead and get started with the Zano CLI
and well off the bat it's just a little bit different than the Zano agent now of
course we're building with an agent and we're also using the Zano developer
MCP for docs and syntax but it's almost different in every other way you can see
here we're in our own IDE of choice cursor VS code cloud code and even
before this I went ahead and authenticated that CLI I downloaded it
installed it I authenticated my account connected to my instance and what's
super cool about this is you can connect to any instance so it's not just grab a
metadata token for each instance and create an MCP server like it used to be
it's streamlined much much more simple so I have this very big prompt here I'm
gonna go ahead and send it through and we'll dissect it so what are we doing
well we're pulling everything in first you'll notice in my local directory I
don't have any workspace files but that'll change in just a second as it of
course pulls from my workspace and here we are our API's that we built so our
medical group our middleware our table so everything that we just built with
the Zano agent is now here in our CLI now of course we can pull we can push
and we can do some really cool things with the CLI tool in fact the CLI has a
bunch of unique feature flags that allow us to do a bunch of very cool things and
let's go ahead and see what we're doing so before we even begin building I am
letting the agent know here I have other files go ahead and look through and see
if you can see Zano script and use those to help build the cool part about this
being local on my system is that it of course has all these other project files
so the more information the better decisions it can make but what are we
actually building that's the question of course well we want to go ahead and
bring life to that the application that we're building we want to go ahead and
enhance it right now it doesn't have audit logging and it doesn't have PHI
encryption so we're gonna go ahead and build that now this prompt is pretty big
it's you could say verbose but before we even start dissecting it I will say
regardless of the model you're using whether it's a front-tier model or not
the more information you give it the better that output so I'm saying add an
audit log table and also go ahead and add some functions I want an audit slash
right for that audit log table I want to go ahead and encrypt and decrypt my PHI
data I want to go ahead and make sure that we're calling this function on
endpoints touching user patient or medical record data also of course for
PHI data we're gonna store it in this underscore ENC field and that's just a
naming convention a suffix we're adding to the column decrypt PHI only when
building API responses and do not log plain PHI perfect so then I have some
additional encryption rules and and this is to say that I'm going ahead and
prompting this in the way that I would go ahead and build I'm catching edge
cases I'm making sure that it is going to build as well concisely as possible
so don't generate you know what it doesn't need to go ahead and use plain
base 64 only do not use base 64 URL and then the same thing more or less for the
encrypt PHI return null when input is null encrypt with the security dot
using AES 256 and then you'll see here the environment PHI encryption key
environment PHI encryption IV perfect that's maybe something that well what
I'll say is I've included this here because we're able to write environment
variables to Xano with the CLI tool which is of course an amazing feature
that hasn't previously existed so now a very hands-off kind of approach when it
comes to building we can go ahead and write all of our logic our tables but
also our environment variables that we can use then in our functions so
continue on with my decrypt PHI saying you know it's gonna operate the same
way of course and then I have some audit logging rules metadata it needs to be
JSON don't insert raw text directly into the audit log metadata etc but you'll
also see seed data rules so what this is really cool and what it's doing is I can
go ahead and seed data in my push so I'll go ahead and push into a workspace
but I can include data with it now why is this important well it's important
especially if we're dealing with a sandbox and that's what we're going to
be doing we're gonna go ahead and create this and we're gonna push it to our
sandbox environment meaning it's gonna be ephemeral and it's not gonna touch
prod it's not gonna touch the live data and it's exciting because what this
really means is it's an additional layer of security for when we develop whether
you're a team of engineers or whether you're solo developing if you have an
application with one user 10,000 users we don't want to push something that
will break prod and make the experience bad so we have of course this
safeguard in place a sandbox only mode so we can go ahead and push everything
to our sandbox now you still absolutely can push directly to prod to the live
branch if you want to not a problem the CLI fully supports that but what you'll
notice is that we're including these flags the environment the records the
dry run we're gonna go ahead and push with no GU IDs we have a bunch of
different things that I've gone ahead and articulated now I have absolutely
spoken to the agent to figure out the best prompt and I would recommend doing
the same rubber ducking with the agent going back and forth and then you know
if any import fails go ahead and follow these instructions so from beginning to
end what I'm saying is this is how I think this is how I build go ahead and
build it like this and as we've been talking that's exactly what it's been
doing it's been modifying these tables we can see removing and adding it's
added the audit lock it's gone ahead and created the functions we'll see now it's
it's been going through these individual endpoints and ensuring that it's been
adding we can see here our function audit right perfect and even before this
it just we're changing a bunch right so as we go through all the way down we'll
also notice let's see here validation has been caught so the CLI is going to
validate the Xanoscript which is always exciting it doesn't matter if you're
using a frontier model or not we have the ability to make sure that the code
that we are going to be testing either in prod or either within the sandbox is
going to be valid and that's what we're seeing here yeah the human in the loop
still 100% yep absolutely very important we're able to catch it of course and
look how fast it just brings up our sandbox environment now I want to go
back real quick here to our IDE it's because it's still gonna be thinking and
let's see so it succeeded the review session opened I'm doing one quick
pullback check from the sandbox so I can confirm what the sandbox now contains
before I wrap up then I might catch another thing and then of course push
another bit but it does let us know everything that's done added the
autolog added the functions added the plain text phi encryption key and
encryption environment and variable so if we go back here click on our keys
here are environment variables that didn't exist when we were creating with
the Xano agent but that do now with of course the CLI tool what I want to go
and see is our data here we don't have any user data it looks like we do have
patient data perfect medical record etc so let's do something here let's go
ahead and add actually let's not even do it from the database let's go to our
API's let's go to our authentication and let's sign up so I'll click run here
this is me this is my email that's a password and I'll go ahead and click
run and it works we can see here it's going to encrypt that PHI it's going to
go ahead and write to the audit log so if I go to my database and I go to my
audit log I can see that this is me it of course is going to include this
this data as it had now we'll go ahead and remove those from previous sandbox
runs we should also be able to see here some of the the the user data that is
me signing up I'm gonna go ahead and create myself as a provider real quick so
we have the name the email encrypted can't see that personal data let's go
ahead and do one additional test we'll go ahead and just simply create a
medical record well first let's create a patient huh that's what we should do
let's click run and I'll select myself and we'll go ahead and pass in our
subject Chris who is so gracious to let us use himself we'll go ahead and click
run and we get this data back now everything's been encrypted though we
can see here in the functions and written here to our audit so going back
to our audit perfect that's a create amazing and we can go and take a look at
the patient that we created that is Chris and so we can say that this is
working the way that we wanted to be working of course you can do more
testing but I want to show you one of the more powerful features that exists
here now of course everything here has been powerful so far but I want to show
you the review and push so I'm gonna click this button in the top right it's
gonna take everything that exists in this ephemeral bit and it's gonna then
put it on the actual workspace that we built with our Xano agent so we'll
review changes we'll go ahead and take a quick look we have this beautiful diff
here allowing us to see all of the changes really just allowing us acting
as you know the human in a loop but also just giving us that visualization of
anything and everything that's changed and providing that confidence right so
let's go ahead and sign off on this we'll say next we're gonna go ahead and
push this to branch 2 we have the ability to set it as a live branch but
we'll just go ahead and push it here right so pushing it I'll go ahead and
deploy and perfect we're no longer in that ephemeral workspace you can see
that banner is gone we are now where we want to be if we go to our API's we can
go ahead and see that everything exists here but what's important is let's just
double take a quick look at our functions our functions exist perfect
okay so we have our right and if we go to our crypto perfect and it exists in
all these endpoints I will need to go ahead and set these environment variables
but ultimately it's assuming more or less that you do have them and if you
don't just go back to the Xano ephemeral environment and go ahead and then of
course Adam but last but not least it's just the fact that we can go ahead and
manage these branches where we can then merge these branches we'll go ahead and
select v2 and we're gonna go ahead and choose the destination as v1 which means
that now we're gonna go ahead and have everything now I will say that we are
looking at destination drafts so we'll go ahead and still include all of these
and it what it says isn't able to merge that's not a problem if a source or
destination branch contains unpublished drafts we deal we still need to go
there simple very easy with what we've done let's go ahead and click on v1
let's go ahead and click on this or I should even click on the publish rather
I can review and publish these changes so I'll just go ahead and publish them
not a problem and I'll go back to v2 and now I'll go back to my manage branch
I'm gonna go ahead and merge my branch from v2 to v1 and now I have all of my
selections and I'll click merge and now v1 is going to have everything that we
just built with the Xano CLI so it's pretty powerful it has a bunch of
features that you can go ahead and leverage to build securely confidently
and well this is the future this is Xano